cash for questions a 90s scandal that
trashed reputations and ended careers
and led to new rules binding politicians
so that mps work for the public and not
for private cash but now former minister
owen patterson has been found by the
common standards committee to have
violated that principle lobbying
government on behalf of two companies
for whom he does paid work
an investigation found that mr
paterson's actions were an egregious
case of paid advocacy he repeatedly used
his privileged position to benefit two
companies for whom he was paid as a
consultant
this has brought the house into
disrepute having ignored mr patterson's
insistence he was acting in the public
interest the proposed penalty was a
30-day suspension from the commons and
an opportunity for the mp's constituents
to vote to have him replaced
or rather that would have been the
sanction if the conservative party with
boris johnson's explicit backing hadn't
chosen this moment to listen to
patterson's objections and use their
majority to tear up and replace the
rulebook
opposition parties deeply uncomfortable
essentially it's like someone who's been
found guilty of a crime but instead of
actually serving a sentence what happens
is that his mates come together and try
to change the judicial system it looks
really bad
sometimes to do the right thing one has
to accept a degree of a program but it
is more important to do the right thing
to ensure that there is uh fairness
the eyes to the right 250.
fair or not the government making its
majority count
shouts of shame in the chamber but in mr
patterson's office satisfaction the case
can now be rerun well i'm very grateful
to the prime minister
jacob rees-mogg andrew ludsum and all
those colleagues who voted for the
amendment
because i now have a chance
to clear my name which i did not have
under the existing system i wouldn't
hesitate to do it again tomorrow
absolutely no no question do you
continue to work for these companies
proudly
yes they're marvelous companies the
chair of the existing standards
committee dumbfounded this is cash for
questions all over again this is
the clearest example i have ever seen of
somebody taking money
to lobby our ministers and officials on
behalf of their paying clients the old
system junked but opposition parties say
they won't participate in a new one
designed by the conservatives this new
committee we have absolutely no
confidence that it's anything but
shambles to allow their conservative mps
off with corruption and with sexual
harassment and all other nasties that
should have no place in parliament what
is not in doubt is that owen paterson
took over a hundred thousand pounds a
year from two companies and then raised
relevant interests with government
officials
and in the row over whether or not that
broke parliament's rules boris johnson
has given the green light to junk the
entire system which polices mps conduct
now cabinet ministers in private will
tell you that these independent
investigators that exist all over
whitehall are often incompetent or
biased but could it be that sometimes
they just don't like what they find
boris johnson's torn up the rule book
time and again pushing back against
checks and balances he does it because
he can and will continue to so long as
the public like him sam coates sky news